we have breaking news to bring you and
the queen's doctors have told her to
rest for at least the next two weeks
let's bring in our royal correspondent
rhiannon mills who's on the phone now
rhiannon what do we know
so in the last few moments we've had a
statement through um from buckingham
palace in which they have said that
following on from their recent advice
that the queen should rest for a few
days her majesty's doctors have advised
that she should continue to rest for at
least the next two weeks now they go on
to say the doctors have advised that her
majesty can continue to undertake light
desk-based duties during this time
including some virtual audiences but not
to undertake any official visits now
they also say it means that her majesty
regrets that this means she'll be unable
to attend
the festival of remembrance on saturday
the 13th of november but they add it
remains that the queen has a firm
intention to be present for the national
service of remembrance on remembrance
sunday so the service that happens at
the cenotaph on the 14th of november so
if we look into more detail about what
they're saying in essence they've said
that the queen's doctors have advised
her that for at least the next two weeks
she has to rest she is able to do some
light desk-based duties but it does mean
that she is not going to attend the
festival of remembrance now that's
an event that happens every year hosted
by the royal british legion uh it's
described as a commemorative event
dedicated to all those that have served
and sacrificed from britain and the
commonwealth and usually we have a huge
party of members of the royal family who
attend that it's on the saturday night
and it's hosted normally at the royal
albert hall again this year it is going
to be at the royal albert hall but as
we're now hearing the queen will not
attend that however and this is really
important they are saying that it
remains the queen's firm intention to be
present for the national service of
remembrance
so that very important service at the
cenotaph which is a focal point a real
moment for the royal family during any
year they're saying that she does still
intend to be there present of course we
know in recent years she has handed over
the responsibility of laying that wreath
on behalf of the nation at the foot of
the cenotaph that responsibility is now
carried out
by the prince of wales but still for the
last few years the queen has been there
on the balcon balcony watching as her
son and heir has carried out that duty
on her behalf also the palace i
understand from them that the queen is
in good spirits of course that has
become
a stock phrase that we've heard them
saying quite a lot also we understand
that she recorded her cop 26 speech this
afternoon of course you have to remember
that it was only on tuesday that we
found out that the queen was no longer
going to be attending that really
important uh reception that she was due
to host at the opening of cop26 she was
due to welcome those world leaders
instead it's now going to be the
responsibility of the prince of wales
the duchess of cornwall and the duke and
duchess of cambridge um also i think for
the palace what they really want to
stress is that light duties are
continuing so yesterday for example we
saw the queen
carrying out a virtual engagement where
she handed over
virtually
a the queen's medal for poetry she was
at windsor castle the recipient was at
buckingham palace um but i think the
overriding message also is that really
the doctors are just trying to be
sensible they're taking every precaution
to make sure that the 95 year old
monarch gets better of course we don't
know what's wrong with her we haven't
been given those details all we know is
that last week she did spend a night in
hospital she did have preliminary tests
what for we don't know
hey rhiannon thank you